welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and what the hell is Marvel
planning on doing with all these dead
celestials TMF for me turtles in the
Indian Ocean has come up again recently
from some unconfirmed rumors about
Captain America new world order from a
couple scoopers but we know marvel
doesn't want us to just forget about
this giant corpse based on a mention of
him and She-Hulk and most recently we
learned the Guardians of the Galaxy and
moved into the skull of another
Celestial nowhere making it home for
home for the refugees after Thanos
Conquest so is this what people just do
with Celestial corpses now turn them
into houses well I speculated after
black panther would kind of forever
confirmed that two vibranium meteorites
struck Earth millions of years apart in
ancient times that this seems like more
than a coincidence at this point and
vibranium as a mineral could in the MCU
be a gift from the celestials for
intelligent life to advance
technologically maybe even Celestial
armor is made out of vibranium and now
in this past week a few online scoopers
are getting worked up with unverified
claims that Captain America New World
Order will revisit the corpse edema as a
contested piece of real estate quick
reminder about what we know about New
World Order this fourth Captain America
film will follow Sam Wilson as Captain
America after the Falcon Winter Soldier
and it's coming May 2024 Harrison Ford
is playing president that is Ross Tim
Blake Nelson is returning from the 2008
Incredible Hulk film as Samuel Stearns
AKA The Leader Carl Lumley as Isaiah
Bradley and Danny Ramirez as Joaquin
Torres aka the new Falcon and Shira Haas
as Ruth bot saraf AKA Sabra based on
Val's confirmation as the MCU CIA
director in wakanda forever and her
interest in acquiring vibrating for the
US government and enrolling Thunderbolts
later that summer I wouldn't be
surprised if Val shows up in this movie
as well then last weekend scooper Daniel
rpk made a series of unverified claims
about New World Order and Thunderbolts
which many believe to be heavily
intertwined story lines now like many
Scoops these have not been verified by
any legitimate news source they
themselves do not constitute news so
take them with a grain of salt because
it's really a coin flip that these kind
of Scoops will end up being [ __ ] but
according to these rumors Tiamat will be
revealed as a valuable Island and a
source of adamantium that's the
vibranium alloy that of course was used
to make Wolverine's skeleton and Claws
and that Tiamat Island will later go by
the name Genosha that in the comics is a
mutant Colony overseen by Magneto the
rumors go on to say that new world order
will feature president Ross and other
countries warrant for control over this
island and not missing a beat another
scooper my time to shine hello weighed
in with their own Scoops speculating
that tieman Island won't be genocia or
even be called team an island as they
believe no one outside the eternals ever
knew the name Tima now there is an easy
fix there you can just make karoon go on
a few podcasts that kind of thing worked
for end game and Scott Lang but you know
whatever but again we do not know how
seriously to take these rumors this
often happens when Marvel announces
highly anticipated titles the following
year and then we start to hear a slow
trickle of casting news but the studios
otherwise silent and these online
accounts start to fill in that Silence
with exciting sounding reports to
varying degrees of reliability but the
reason I'm exploring this today is that
Marvel Studios is transitioning from
phase four to phase five definitely
leaving us with some loose thread
Curiosities like the status of
celestials the physical nature of
celestials and the role of vibranium as
a resource in the eternals film a news
report hinted at the public reaction to
tiamat's marbleized form in the ocean
the sudden appearance of an enormous
Stone figure in the Indian Ocean has
left more questions than answers for
authorities U.S and Australian Daniel
ships are maintained defensive positions
and we don't really hear the rest of the
report but you can make out the reporter
saying quote no reports of movement and
quote by the White House so it's clear
based on this that world governments
have taken interest in Demon and maybe
the reason no one in the MCU is talking
about diamet aside from a recommended
link appearing on a website in She-Hulk
is because this is become a top secret
disputed Zone a kind of no man's land
that no media let alone any military
forces could try to go anywhere near
kind of like the Chinese building
islands in the South China Seas so that
they can try to claim Naval authority
over those Waters and those shipping
lanes in addition to a Potential Threat
to Global ecology and sea levels that
have explored in other videos Tina is a
major Game Changer to geopolitics and
international relations in the MCU it is
also long but established that
celestial's corpses are just valuable
resources in general for various
lucrative Commodities when the collector
owned nowhere in the Guardians of the
Galaxy film his Devon Corporation mined
this skull for brain tissue and spinal
fluid for sale now the Guardians of the
Galaxy own this location and have turned
it into a home which suggests that 101
might have cleared the skull of any
minable resources or maybe he found a
more valuable mining opportunity to move
his operations too like perhaps the rest
of the body of nowhere but black panther
were kind of forever confirmed that the
people of telecon had their own
heart-shaped herb and their own deposits
of vibranium in the Gulf of Mexico off
the coast of the Yucatan Peninsula
there's a good chance that that was the
six Lube impact event that was the
asteroid that hit Earth 66 million years
ago that's when they killed the
dinosaurs and created the sheiksulu
crater that actually could have been the
same impact that we saw in the Eternal
film when the celestials planted the
celestial seed that would one day grow
into tiemann that asteroid clearly
created a shock wave and broke off
mineral deposits as it burrowed toward
the core of the earth so with that is
our Missing Link vibranium came to Earth
from celestials Seema could indeed be a
source of vibranium on the planet and
when Cersei transformed him into Marvel
that vibranium in him could have taken
on a new form as well a form known as
adamantium in the comics adamantium is
named after the fabled metal adamantine
from Greek mythology who knows in the
MCU if people don't know tmit's name
they could just call this thing Adam and
derive the name that way remember
She-Hulk also included that other
headline man fights with metal claws and
Barbara So if we do take that as a
legitimate Wolverine reference
adamantium must already be in a liquid
form and Weapon X must already be
underway I honestly do believe that
Marvel Studios is going to find some
purpose for tiamat's corpse this video
always circles back to repurpose old
plot threads and characters even for
movies the studio you could say has
reasons to let fans forget like bringing
back both Abomination and the leader
from the 2008 Edward Norton Hulk film
and then setting major portions of
Avengers endgame during the events of
Thor the Dark World and of course shung
Chi owning up to Iron Man 3 using the
name of the Mandarin as well as bringing
back Trevor Slattery and extremist
soldiers so Tiamat is just too big to
ignore in the MCU and too rich of a
playground to leave unexplored now yeah
there might be more livable habitats
than giant marble fingers for mutants to
settle on and call Genosha and really we
have to meet some X-Men before we can
establish a genosa but as an adamantium
mine that gets blown to Hell by
countries bombing it so that other
countries can't mine it and a president
Red Hulk smashed into bits that's a
pretty fun way to use a giant corpse let
me know your thoughts on all this and
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
And subscribe to new Rockstar store more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]